[Music]
just when we thought that we couldn't be
any more excited for frozen to a brand
new trailer comes out and proves us
wrong keep watching to find out why Elsa
might end up saving the entire world
here are 10 things everyone missed in
the new frozen 2 trailer the glass horse
the brand-new frozen 2 trailer starts
off in a very similar fashion as the
first one we see Elsa freezing the ocean
and attempting to run across it but this
time we catch a glimpse of her swimming
underwater when she's seconds away from
the surface a glass-like horse appears
in front of her it almost seems like
it's trying to stop her from reaching
the top the horse seems angry at first
but after looking at Elsa it changes its
tune and explodes into tiny shards of
ice we know that Elsa can create
sentient ice beans
but it almost looks like this horse was
sent to stop her from resurfacing the
past is not what it seems we didn't see
the trolls rockin and rollin their way
to Elsa side grandpappy tells Elsa that
the pass is not what it seems
we then catch a glimpse of Elsa as a kid
so do Elsa's powers emanates from the
Northern Lights
if so Elsa's entire upbringing might be
alive because this would mean that she
wasn't born with her powers they were
given to her the horses back
grandpappy tells Elsa
[Music]
across the enchanted land once again we
see a nice horse
prancing across the screen but this time
it looks like Elsa is the one
controlling it
huge boulder like creatures appear
giving us the notion that our heroes
will encounter these monsters throughout
their journey ice castle
grand pabbie informs Elsa Anna and the
gang that they will have to venture
north we then see our heroes journeying
across the frozen landscape but if you
hit the pause button you'll see where
Elsa Anna Kristoff Sven and Olaf are
going in the background there's a
mountain with the glowing ice castle in
speak to our heroes probably are heading
to this castle to uncover the truth
about Elsa's past turns out Elsa isn't
the only one who likes building ice
castles on mountain peaks the enchanted
lands the first frozen two trailers
showcased our heroes traveling through a
forest in the fall it's foggy and
mysterious and the trees are filled with
red leaves Elsa and her friends must
journey across it and into the unknown
we then see Anna and Olaf rowing this
small boat down a hidden waterfall it
looks like our heroes are going to split
up be it by accident or by necessity
Olaf and Anna looked terrified but this
might be the only way out of the
enchanted lands the pink flames get it
together
control it although it has yet to be
confirmed
it looks like the villain of the story
can create pink flames I quickly devour
its surroundings we see a group of
people walking through the enchanted
lands only to be stopped when a pink
flames start to jumping across the
forest and setting things on fire
this flame was shown in the first frozen
film when grandpappy warned King a ganar
and Queen abouna about their daughter's
abilities Elsa might be the one
responsible for the pink flames after
all the flames start off as blue energy
only to become pink Kristoff saves Anna
right after we see the pink flame set
the trees ablaze we see Kristoff riding
on spends back and scooping Anna up in
his arms but if you pause here you can
see Elsa kneeling in the distance it's
almost as if Kristoff is saving Anna
from her very own sister grand pabbie
warned our heroes about the enchanted
lands so it's possible that this magical
forest brings Elsa's powers to a whole
new level one that she can't even begin
to control Elsa's powers Elsa's powers
are no joke they mean business in every
sense of the word when the king and
queen of arendelle first brought Anna
and Elsa to the trolls grandpa V asked
king Agner born with the powers of
cashed born and they're getting stronger
grandpa Vee says we have always feared
that Elsa's powers were too much for
this world
now we must hope they are enough
grandpappies revelation basically
confirms that a very powerful person or
entity could potentially destroy the
world and it looks like Elsa is the only
one who can defeat it but don't sweat it
Elsa no pressure at all the mysterious
symbols in the frozen to trailer we see
some strange crystal like rhombuses
appear in thin air we then see Anna
looking at them from her bedroom balcony
well the second frozen two trailer
basically confirms what many of us
suspected Elsa is responsible for these
mysterious symbols Elsa's powers are
clearly becoming more powerful than
before fans were quick to point out that
for recurring symbols could be found in
the rhombuses and it looks like they
were seriously onto something
destination unknown
once Anna Elsa Kristoff Sven and Olaf
are safely out of the enchanted land
across a huge cloud of fog Elsa uses her
powers to disperse the fog revealing
four large rock structures it looks like
our heroes have reached their
destination but wait what are those
symbols on the large stone totem poles
they're the exact same symbols we see in
the crystal like rhombuses Elsa's about
to find out the truth about her powers
and where they come from could the four
seasons have something to do with Elsa's
abilities and who's responsible for the
pink flames sound off in the comments
section below and that's a wrap thanks
for watching the things as usual don't
forget to give this video a big thumbs
up for more videos like this one hit
that subscribe button we'll catch you
later
[Music]